cuando vemos fotografías de astronautas
que se encuentran en el espacio no
parece que haya gravedad alguna que esté
trabajando en ese caso verdad todo
parece que se encuentra flotando nada
nada se encuentra cayendo en cierta
dirección de hecho ni siquiera es claro
qué es lo que de sarri va o qué es lo
que es abajo todo simplemente parece
estar flotando y por ejemplo si
empujamos este muro hacia acá
simplemente se iría flotando en esa
dirección así que no parece que hubiera
alguna influencia de la gravedad que
está jalando las cosas hacia abajo pero
la cuestión es que los astronautas aún
no están muy lejos de un cuerpo
supermasivo verdad por ejemplo este de
hecho un transbordador espacial por
ejemplo este podríamos ponerlo a un par
de un par de cientos de miles de
kilómetros no quizás aún a unos cientos
de kilómetros arriba de la tierra que a
lo mejor podríamos pintarlo justo aquí
verdad así que en eso
la dibujamos es en esa escala
simplemente podría estar ahí verdad y
sabemos que la fuerza de gravedad entre
dos objetos es igual es decir o bueno
más bien la magnitud de la fuerza de
gravedad entre dos objetos es igual a la
constante de la gravitación universal
que es nuestra que mayúscula verdad que
multiplica a la primer masa del primer
objeto por la masa del segundo objeto y
dividimos entre la distancia entre estos
dos objetos al cuadrado verdad y si el
transbordadores se encuentra justo aquí
sólo a unos cientos de kilómetros arriba
de la superficie de la tierra en
realidad está r no es muy diferente
verdad que si estamos solo sobre la
superficie de la tierra estamos un
poquito más allá de que si estuviéramos
en la superficie pero recordemos que la
r se mide de donde se encuentra el
centro de la tierra a dónde se encuentra
el centro del objeto verdad el centro de
masa que lo podrías consultar en otro de
los vídeos que tenemos en cana académico
el centro de la tierra representa
digamos la mayor distancia que podrá que
podríamos encontrar a la superficie
así que si estamos en la superficie o a
unos cientos de kilómetros arriba de la
superficie de la tierra no va a cambiar
drásticamente esta r al menos en
términos porcentuales así que cuando lo
vemos de esta forma que estamos a unos
cientos de kilómetros arriba de la
tierra no debería ser muy distinta a la
magnitud de la fuerza de la gravedad y
de hecho déjenme quitar esta flechita
porque no es un vector este es una
magnitud muy bien
así que la pregunta que te hago es la
siguiente si no si si la gravedad existe
aunque estemos a esa altura esa
distancia del centro de la tierra como
es que queremos que esta estas imágenes
verdad donde la gente está flotando
por el espacio con los de esta forma
como es que se puede lograr esto se
hagan unas y si hay influencia de la
gravedad y la respuesta es que esta
gravedad que sé que podemos hallar en el
espacio en realidad está haciendo que la
gente esté cayendo simplemente que se
están moviendo muy rápido en relación a
lo bueno se están moviendo muy rápido
relativamente a la tierra y simplemente
están pasando la vamos a vamos a ver a
tratar de dibujar lo que estoy diciendo
digamos que nos encontramos por aquí nos
estamos en áfrica
ok tenemos una resortera súper súper
súper poderosa muy bien y lanzamos una
piedra con nuestra reportera ya lo mejor
esa piedra se mueve en este
digamos de esta forma muy bien entonces
te das cuenta que es súper poderosa
porque la pudimos mover de esa piedra
varios kilómetros qué tal qué lo hacemos
un poco más fuerte que qué tal que ahora
lo hacemos más fuerte y cae aquí muy
bien y qué tal que ahora lo hacemos un
poco más fuerte vamos a intentarlo un
poco más fuerte
y ahora cae aquí en el océano índico o
no sé en esta parte muy bien qué tal que
ahora lo hacemos todavía más fuerte más
más fuerte y quizás ya estás viendo a
dónde es a lo que quiero llegar verdad
todavía más fuerte más fuerte ok y
entonces lo que va ocurriendo ahí me
salió muy mal esta trayectoria lo que va
ocurriendo es que cada vez va llegando a
una mayor distancia cada vez va llegando
a una mayor distancia pero va a llegar a
un momento a cierta velocidad crítica en
donde ya no se va ya no va a caer
digamos digamos vamos a pintarlo con
azul que hacemos esta trayectoria que
ella va tan rápido que ubs bueno ok se
me pasó un poco
aunque ya va tan rápido que ya no vales
ya no parece caer de nuevo a la tierra
sino simplemente se queda en órbita
dándole vueltas a la tierra muy bien
esta es la idea de cómo es que la
gravedad si tiene una cierta influencia
sobre los cuerpos que están orbitando
por encima de la tierra
por ejemplo si no hubiera gravedad y
nosotros lanzamos nuestra piedra con
nuestra resortera en realidad está
literalmente se escapa por la tangente
verdad pero como si hay una gravedad
esto está jalando la piedra hacia el
centro en cada en cada momento entonces
eso es lo que provoca que esté orbitando
alrededor de la tierra así que en
resumen la fuerza de gravedad lo que
está haciendo es eso está curvando la
trayectoria de este objeto y si va
suficientemente rápido el proyectil o el
objeto cualquiera que estemos hablando
si va suficientemente rápido
simplemente se mantendrá girando y
girando alrededor de la tierra aunque
digamos realmente para nuestros
propósitos podemos suponer que no hay
aire a estas alturas verdad a estas
alturas astronómicas
y realmente bueno no hay suficiente aire
especialmente a estas alturas muy bien
por ejemplo a la que las estaciones
espaciales se mueven así que podríamos
despreciar toda la resistencia del aire
y todo ese lastre que se puede generar
de esa forma aunque en la práctica si
hay cierto pequeño arrastre o hay cierta
cierta resistencia al aire y eso
provoca que a lo largo del tiempo
tengamos satélites que van desacelerando
porque hay cierta resistencia ok
entonces la respuesta está a este
cuestionamiento que hacíamos es que
realmente si hay gravedad no es un
ambiente libre de gravedad simplemente
estos astronautas que se encuentran en
las estaciones espaciales si están
cayendo pero se están moviendo
suficientemente su suficientemente
rápido como para que nunca golpeen de
nuevo la tierra muy bien y de hecho este
si pusieran por ejemplo no sé si ellos
estuvieran aquí y de alguna forma
pusieran un freno entonces
inmediatamente esto es la fuerza de
gravedad los jalar y así el centro de la
tierra
y caerían se desplomarían hacia el
centro de la tierra así que no hay nada
especial de ir a 300 o 400 kilómetros
por arriba de la superficie en el
espacio simple no no es que la gravedad
de repente desaparezca sino que la
influencia de la gravedad hasta cierto
punto sigue sigue siendo válida pero
está generando que el movimiento sea de
tipo va con digamos está generando que
orbiten nuestro objeto alrededor de la
tierra
ahora una cuestión muy interesante es
qué pasaría si nosotros quisiéramos
simular la gravedad y de hecho esto es
lo que la nasa hace para simular la
gravedad
ok digamos que ponen a gente en un avión
déjenme pintar aquí digamos el suelo
ahí está el suelo ok y ponemos gente en
un avión y de hecho a esto le llaman
como el cohete de vómito o algo por el
estilo porque se sabe que hace que la
gente se enferme no se maree y
simplemente simplemente lo que hacen es
digamos poner este proyectil el avión en
donde va la gente en movimiento entonces
ya hemos visto que se genera un
movimiento parabólico aunque eso no se
parece mucho a una parábola
ahí está se genera un movimiento
parabólico al
al trazar digamos la trayectoria de este
proyectil ok así que este avión o este
cohete lo que sea que utilice la nasa
hará simplemente ese recorrido pero
digamos se va a sentir una caída libre
así que cualquiera que se encuentre
sobre nuestro objeto nuestro avión a
nuestro cohete va a experimentar la
caída libre así que si has estado
digamos en si ha saltado en bondi o si
has hecho este paracaidismo algo de ese
estilo o incluso cuando te subes a una
montaña rusa y justo estás hasta arriba
y te dejas caer entonces de repente tu
estómago se siente hoy como como como
raro no como si se subiera y esas
sensaciones de la caída libre es
exactamente la misma sensación que
tienen los astronautas porque están en
constante caída libre solo qué
no es distinguible de por ejemplo si
estás muy lejos digamos por acá de un
súper cuerpo como como la tierra no es
distinguible si estás lejos o si estás
cerca ok así que si alguien se encuentra
sobre sobre una estación espacial y no
tiene ventanas no hay ninguna forma de
saber si están cerca o lejos de un
objeto masivo y simplemente estarán en
caída libre alrededor de él
estarán en órbita cuando estén
suficientemente o cuando tengan aún una
suficiente o una razonable velocidad y
que estén suficientemente también lejos
de ese objeto pero en cualquier forma si
existe la gravedad